et c'est avec antoine fenaux bonjour
antoine ce soir 2-1 fox qui cible les
musulmans oui effectivement raphaël 2-1
fox dans deux pays différents avec un
but pointé du doigt la soi-disant
intolérance de l'islam et de la
communauté musulmane premier exemple
autour du burkina en france évidemment
autour de cette décision de la mairie de
grenoble vous vous en souvenez ces
dernières autorisé ce maillot de bain
islamique dans les piscines de la ville
décision qui a provoqué une vive
polémique en france certains en ont
d'ailleurs profité pour propager des
infos avec ce tweet par exemple il a été
retweeté plus de mille fois notamment il
montre une photo d'une pancarte dernière
montre que bien que le burqini est
interdit donc dans une à ce qui
ressemble apparemment une piscine on
voit que le texte est écrit à la fois en
arabe et en français le tweet lui juste
au dessus il dit et bien pour vivre à
l'européenne on va bientôt s'expatrier
au maroc on marche sur la tête non au
burkina d'air vous voyez le nom de cet
utilisateur bruno attal utilisateurs lui
ce n'est pas n'importe qui brûlait
atteint est en effet syndicaliste
policier et il est candidat du parti
d'extrême droite reconquête celui d'eric
zemmour aux législatives dans le rhône à
noter d'ailleurs que cette photo est un
que je vous ai montré a été largement
parts partager et reprise par les
sympathisants de ce parti donc rafael
voilà pour le contacter dans les faits
le maroc interdite il ou non le burkini
mais bien non les pour retrouver
l'origine de cette photo comme
d'habitude il suffit de procéder une
simple recherche d'image inversée dans
ce cas là si on fait ça on retombe sur
plusieurs articles illustrés avec cette
photo notamment celui ci que j'ai choisi
pour vous de la presse marocaine qui
donne le fin mot de l'histoire plusieurs
établissements privés marocains c'est en
2014 à ont décidé d'interdire ce
vêtement de bain dans leur établissement
le site bladi ici nous explique
l'origine de ces décisions ne tel d'el
hadj avait pris cette décision
d'interdire le burqini pour des raisons
d'hygiène dans les piscines décision qui
avait fait polémique dans le royaume et
pourtant dans sillage et même plusieurs
autres d'état établissement que qui
regroupe donc des piscines au maroc
avait pris la même décision les
dernières nouvelles la dass et relaie
également la même photo on la retrouve
d'ailleurs sur un article et avec un
commentaire d'un lecteur assidu des arts
nouvelles d'alsace qui affirme que cette
photo a été prise dans le complexe
aquatique d'oise ziriat à marrakech là
encore l'interdiction a été prise pour
des raisons d'hygiène et si on retrouve
et bien sûr google mc on retrouve
effectivement que wazi rien que l'on
aperçoit derrière moi avec ces photos
que j'ai choisis pour vous se trouve
bien autour de marrakech et j'ai choisi
n'ont qu'une de ses photos de ce
complexe et vous voyez raphaël peut-être
ici si j'arrive à zoomer voilà les
panneaux verts que vous apercevez
justicier à l'entrée du portique de
l'établissement et bien ce sont les
mêmes la main des extraits de cette
photo que l'on a pu voir et avec cette
interdiction du burkini et pour en être
totalement sûres sont sur un an sur le
site de cet établissement donc loisirs
ya deux malades de marrakech et sur les
la foire aux questions que propose
beaucoup de sites internet et bien il ya
un paragraphe qui se pose la question le
burqini est il utilisé et bien non le
burqini n'est pas autorisée au sein
d'établissements pour des régions
d'hygiène et de sécurité dont confusion
vous le voyez raphaël pas d'interdiction
du burkini au maroc en tout cas pas
général et pas décidée par le royaume du
maroc mais des interdictions dans
certains lieux privés avec à la clé une
instrumentalisation par l'extrême droite
française la communauté musulmane
ciblées à en france donc mais c'est
aussi le cas ailleurs dans le monde oui
absolument et tristement notamment en
inde le parti au pouvoir vous le savez
de narendra modi a fait du nationalisme
hindou une doctrine avec des
conséquences dramatiques pour les
musulmans là les musulmans du pays en
2020 souvenez-vous l'adoption d'une loi
sur la nationalité avait à 2 avait
déclenché des violences contre cette
communauté et sur twitter a bien
récemment certains indiens notamment
cible la communauté musulmane à coude un
fox exemple avec cette vidéo relayée que
je ne vais pas vous jouez par un
utilisateur un drain l'extrait est assez
insoutenable la femme que vous voyez ici
à terre se fait tabasser il faut bien
dire par un homme de manière assez
atroce l'utilisateur lui la firme il
s'agit d'une aux états unis d'une femme
musulmane frappé par son frère parce
qu'elle veut sortir avec un non musulman
la vérité vous en doutez est loin de
cette affirmation avec là encore une
simple recherche d'image un v on
retrouve l'origine de cette vidéo cette
fois sur un site d'un média pro
gouvernementale russe un article daté du
5 juillet 2021 on le voit ici ce dernier
nous apprend que le drame en question ne
s'est pas déroulé aux états unis mais en
russie à krasnodar elle se déroule dans
la communauté gitane
la jeune femme et avait effectivement
rencontré un ukrainien un homme
ukrainien sur internet elle avait fait
il avait loué une relation amoureuse est
décidée se marier avec lui il avait donc
fui le domicile où elle habitait pour le
rejoindre a été rattrapé et ramené de
force chez elle par ses les membres de
sa communauté elle ça leur fait frapper
par son frère l'homme que l'on que l'on
voit dans un peu plus loin dans la vidéo
que je ne vous ai pas montré des proches
pour la petite histoire de la jeune
femme ont rapporté les faits à la police
russe sans réaction malheureusement donc
en résumé raphaëlle vous le voyez la
femme n'est pas musulmane c'est un drame
sordide instrumentalisée par un
internaute indien pour jeter le
discrédit sur les musulmans 2-1 fox deux
cibles les musulmans et la vérité comme
souvent merci antoine fenaux c'était
info ou intox avec antoine on se
retrouve dans moins de cinq minutes
rester avec nous dans pareils actes